having grown up in the uk from my
experience myths and folklore are not
really something prioritized on the
school curriculum i can remember
learning some simple greek and egyptian
stories but that's about it really
the vast range of folklore across the
british isles was never really explored
at least not until much later when you
could do your own reading and you start
to see its influences in all sorts of
fiction today i'll be focusing on the
stories and legends of england but no
need to worry wales scotland and ireland
are all deserving of their own videos
in store today we have tales of swamp
hags demon dogs giant slayers and
and a pair of hairy hands
sorry
murderous ghostly hairy hands
there is a difference stick around and
you may just find out
before we go any further a quick word
from today's sponsor masterworks from
1995 all the way until last year
contemporary art has had an annual
appreciation of 13.6
whereas the s p 500 sits at about 9.6
percent so why don't more people invest
in contemporary art you may be asking
well the barrier to entry has always
been rather steep the average person
can't afford to buy paintings worth
millions however with masterworks it is
now possible to invest in some of the
world's most iconic pieces of artwork
their research team determines which
artist markets have the most momentum
and purchase the art pieces at a fair
price the shares for the art pieces are
then made available for anyone wishing
to invest the painting is held anywhere
between three to ten years and then sold
which is when you receive your portion
of the sale alternatively you can sell
your shares on the secondary market to
someone else before the painting is sold
getting started with masterworks is as
simple as signing up to the website
which only takes a few clicks you then
have access to their entire database so
you can do your own research as well as
having assistance from their expert team
that will ensure you have a diverse
portfolio
there is currently a waiting list
however you can bypass this and start
investing today by using my link in the
description it also goes a long way in
supporting the channel
stories of dangerous spirits and
creatures lurking around the lakes and
riverbeds across england are fairly
common there is the grendilo small green
humanoids who stalk the riverbeds for
children to drown there is also peg
prowler who does the same thing but
disguised as an old hag
but the worst of these is jenny
greenteath who does not discriminate and
drowns both the young and the elderly
jenny is also known as ginny or wicked
jenny and her stories exist
predominantly around the north of
england around liverpool lancashire and
the surrounding counties
her name refers to the green tint of her
skin and her razor sharp teeth
the easiest way to describe jenny is as
a river or swamp hag the bogeyman or
bogey woman of the lakes and rivers
children were warned to stay away from
dangerous bodies of water otherwise
jenny would find them and drag them in
jenny could blend into her surroundings
so well she was essentially invisible to
the naked eye what may seem like an
ordinary stagnant pond may have a
nightmarish hag waiting under the
surface
she was also used as a way to scare
children into brushing their teeth if
you didn't keep them clean
well
jenny would find you so brushing your
teeth not only helps you avoid cavities
and other dental issues but it may also
stop you being drowned by an old hag who
also happens to have horrendous teeth
absolute hypocrite jenny herself is
closely associated with bodies of water
surrounded and covered by duckweed which
can make the water seem like solid
ground and is rather dangerous for
anyone particularly children who are
unaware stories like this are the
perfect example of folklore and its
purpose yes these stories can be
interesting and sometimes scary but they
also have a greater purpose or moral
behind them
our next legend is one you may be
familiar with without exactly hearing
his story jack the giant killer this is
a great one for me because growing up
jack in the beanstalk was easily one of
my favorite fairy tales
this story takes place during the reign
of king arthur
our main character jack is the son of a
cornish farmer
jack is smart and strong destined to be
more than just a farmer like his father
not that there's anything wrong with
being a farmer jack just wanted
something more adventurous
one day he came across the giant
cormoran who was known to the farmers
because of his taste for livestock he
wisely decided against a confrontation
later when he went into town he
overheard members in the town hall
talking about the giant and so jack
spoke up inquiring about what type of
reward he would be given
they looked at jack and scoffed
the giant's treasure shall be your
reward
and so jack accepted
knowing he couldn't fight the giant
head-on he took a shovel a horn and a
pickaxe over to where he last saw
cormoran
during the night he took the shovel and
began to dig a hole by the morning he
had created a pit trap over 20 feet deep
which he covered with sticks and straw
to disguise the hole
he placed himself on one side of the
trap and began to blow his horn
with the ground shaking the giant
labored over
why are you blowing that horn so loud
while i sleep
i'm gonna boil your bones for breakfast
the giant ran towards jack and fell into
the pit trap leaving only his head
exposed now with the playing field even
jack took his pickaxe and killed
cormoran
shortly after he found the giant's
treasure and once the town magistrates
had heard of his victory he was dubbed
jack the giant slayer and given a sword
and a belt
hearing of cormoran's demise another
giant blunderborg vowed vengeance
against this newly crowned giant slayer
blunderborg was known for kidnapping
lords and ladies eating the men and
taking the women for wives
he would eat the husbands in front of
the wives and if they refused to join in
on this twisted feast then he would take
them and hang them by their hair in his
dungeon until they starve not a very
pleasant fellow as you can imagine
jack exhausted from his travels stopped
for a drink and a rest at a nearby town
whilst asleep unfortunately jack is
found by blunderboar who takes him back
to his castle and throws him in his
dungeon
excited about his new find blunderborn
invited another giant to his castle so
they could feast on jack together in
this time however jack manages to escape
the dungeon and with some rope he
fashions two nooses
when the giants arrived he tied the rope
to a wooden beam
he then slid down and threw the nooses
over the giants distracted by the ropes
around their necks jack was able to
swing across and slice their throats
with his sword
jack then freed all of the women being
held captive in blunderborg's castle
in wales jack met a two-headed giant who
offered him a room for the night however
jack was weary of the giant's intentions
and so he placed a pile of wood under
his bed sheets and left the room the
giant believing jack was asleep entered
his room and with his enormous club
smashed the bed into pieces hearing the
cracking of the wood he was convinced he
had broken all of jack's bones and
returned to his room satisfied the next
morning jack walked into the giant's
room to thank him for his hospitality
perplexed as to how jack was still alive
he asked him if he felt anything during
the night to which jack replied merely a
rat slapping me with his tail the giant
took offense
on the table were two bowls of fresh
porridge before leaving jack challenged
him to an eating contest and the giant
accepted
jack pretended to pour the porridge into
his mouth however it went straight into
a bag inside of his coat pocket when the
giant tried to do the same the porridge
burnt his throat
he then told the giant he could perform
a trick that the giant could not
possibly copy he took his knife and
stabbed himself in the stomach slicing
open the bag of porridge the giant
believing jack had just sliced open his
own belly was sick and tired of being
outstaged by him he took the knife and
plunged it into his own stomach shortly
after dropping dead
jack had succeeded in making the giant
slay himself and so he continued on with
his journey soon after he came across
king arthur's son to whom he pledged his
servitude
as jack continued his duties he would be
crowned a knight of the round table the
knight who was known for killing giants
black anis or black agnes is another
bogeyman type figure spoken of in the
english midlands annis was also known as
the cannibal hag who lived in a cave in
the dane hills in leicestershire at the
base of this cave was a great oak tree
that she would hide in waiting for
children to pass by so she could devour
them
she was described as an unusually tall
blue-faced hag with long iron claws who
feeds off the flesh of children
parents would warn their children if you
do not behave then black anise will come
for you at night when you lay in your
bed
at night she stalks the fields slaying
lambs and wearing their skin around her
waist using the branches of oak trees to
conceal herself as she ventures closer
to nearby houses she would enter houses
through the windows and snatch children
away
legend says that houses in
leicestershire were built with smaller
windows than usual to make it as hard as
possible for anis to enter however she
could still reach inside with her long
arms
to stop this households would fasten
animal skin across their windows and
place witch herbs above and beneath the
windows to keep hanis away
her origin stories are slightly
confusing there are greek egyptian and
mesopotamian theories all thrown in
there as well as the celtic mother
goddess anu also known as danu there are
some however who argue the legend of
anus was inspired by agnes scott a nun
who was known for caring for the nearby
leper colony she also lived inside of a
cave in the churchyard historian ronald
hutton believes over time her image
became distorted into a secluded hag
that would be used to scare children
into behaving themselves this modern
image was then popularized through a
poem written by john heyrick
to said the soul of mortal man recoiled
to view black hanus's eye so fierce and
wild vast talons foul with human flesh
there grew in place of hands and
features livid blue glared in her visage
whilst her obscene waste warm skins of
human victims close embraced not without
terror they the cave survey where hung
the monstrous trophies of her sway to
said that in the rock large rooms were
found
scooped with her claws beneath the
flinty ground
to this day black anis still serves as a
bogeyman figure although the similarity
in name to the goddess anu has caused a
moderate amount of interest from wiccan
groups who believe she is the
personification of anu in crone form
the black chuck is one of the many black
dogs or hellhounds found across the
british isles stories of the black shark
are most common in east anglia norfolk
suffolk cambridgeshire and essex
its name derives from its appearance as
a large shaggy black dog that also has a
rather ghostly aura
shock itself came from the old english
meaning devil or fiend hence why when
it's first mentioned by e.s taylor it is
referred to as shuck the dog fiend
this phantom i have heard many persons
in east norfolk and even cambridgeshire
described as having seen a black shaggy
dog with fiery eyes and of immense size
and who visits churchyards at midnight
one witness nearly fainted away at
seeing it
the name appears to be a corruption of
shag as shocky is the norfolk dialogue
for shaggy is not this the vestige of
the german dog fiend
what taylor was discussing here were the
sightings of large black dogs during the
night at roadsides cemeteries and
churchyards
these claims were never substantiated
however there isn't a large pool of
animals that could have been confused
for a black dog the size of a horse
another origin for these stories goes
back to the vikings who settled on the
norfolk coast they told stories of a
black hound that belonged to the god
odin others claimed it was the war hound
of thor but i've never seen any of these
mentioned in any of the norse sagas
its fiery red eyes are sometimes
described as just one big red eye in the
middle of its head like a cyclops
if you are unfortunate enough to see its
eye it is considered a sign or warning
that your death is only one year away
the black shark still remains a mystery
and is even still referenced to this day
the last legend today is also perhaps
the weirdest in the county of devon
there is a stretch of road in dartmoor
that is haunted by a ghost however it is
no ordinary ghost
the stories call them the unseen hands
or more commonly the hairy hands
a pair of hands that suddenly appear to
those driving down this road the hands
grab the steering wheel of the victim's
car and tried to cause them to veer
off-road and crash over the years many
accidents and deaths were attributed to
these mysterious hands
some claim that they saw the hands and
others say they were invisible but they
felt an uneasy presence in their car the
1920s saw a steep rise in these
sightings in 1921 the newspapers
published a story that became nationwide
news a man stated that a pair of
invisible hands had taken control of him
and forced him to crash his motorcycle
in 1924 a woman camping with her husband
saw a pair of hands enter her caravan
late at night
after making the sign of a cross the
hands quickly left the scene
the hairy hands are certainly strange
but given how dangerous it may have been
driving on some of these winding and
poorly lit roads cautionary tales
similar to their hairy hands do make
some sense
kind of
hopefully you've enjoyed this one let me
know which of today's stories were your
favorite
as always i've been your host mythology
and fiction explained
you